good morning John and good morning
nerdfighters today we're gonna have a
special episode of question Tuesday
where we answer real questions from real
nerdfighters this time with my real dad
and my real mom that's me
also your real dad in real mom unless
you've got something that you want to
tell us today so how are you feeling
nervous
I don't do in front of the camera dad
makes films um we this is where we got
it from no yeah oh you did oh you're not
gonna do a whole new better thing yours
question I have for you is from Angus
why did you name your son William if you
were gonna call him Hank
I'll also like nothing answer this
question because the bank doesn't like
it okay because we're southern we wanted
to name you after your grandfather's so
that was William Henry didn't want you
to be the bill or Willy or bill or Willy
we like Hank we thought it was cute baby
Hank but I realize it's been a
monumental pay the our life I remember
being like 13 years old and not knowing
how to spell William did you have
alternate names for us if we were gonna
be girls oh do I have a girl name out
there somewhere yeah not for you I knew
you were a boy how did you know I was a
boy magic witchcraft yes pretty much but
you did have one for John yes Elizabeth
how did you feel when I came out a boy I
was perfectly fine with that mostly
happy that you were out and breathing um
very little tent over a little blue yeah
yeah yeah it's um I don't have a memory
or bad blue you don't have a real high
Apgar score John's grades were higher
even then what does an Apgar scores that
just like they say color school they had
just have like a colored you're likely
to both omit his line it up and then I
okay there you go I absolutely think
that's what it is but I'm based on my
political science degree what was John
like as a child horrible Wow
I didn't even let me finish the sentence
he was a wonderful child very troubled
unique if my mother would say only that
was always into embellishing the choice
for walking through the Miami Airport
and he's like five and year three we're
carrying you and he's walking carrying
this Paul is whole bag and he just lies
down calmly no no tantrums he just lies
down on his back in the airport and says
it's just too much I can't take it
anymore
one time you just finally got tired up
I'm yelling at you and you took a hammer
to him because you couldn't talk really
at that time Europe why did I have a
hammer no no mom yes how did you raise
such perfect children your friends and
family understand what we do your honor
they clearly understand what John do
yeah they understand what you do and and
the videos and every day our stuff no no
no it always surprises me and kind of
amuses me that there are people who go
is Hank okay with the fact that John is
so famous and so successful I'm not
though you think I am
hahaha and she wants to know has anyone
really been far even as decided to use
even go want to do look more like yes
what's your number one parenting tip
encouraged Wow
just one word to your father would say
is number in marriage tip is persistence
and so may be my number one parenting
tip is along the same lines henry rice
says unohana
oh yeah how did you decide to live where
you do we near Asheville 20 minutes
outside Asheville spread sheet that had
indicators on social well-being and
individual well-being and almost all the
indicators came from the census so we
wanted use exact is that what you're
saying you I mean ask your way to your
new home can we're such nerds what what
is up with this my friend made it she's
wearing Chanel look she's got bloomers
yeah yeah she does
thanks for being my mom oh it takes for
being my son thanks for supporting us uh
throughout all of this and also as you
know my dad throughout all of the rest
of my life everybody my dad
for everybody I personally love the fact
that it's time for project for awesome
that's my favorite time of year by